Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Lego Batman Easter
egg and references video.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
movie yet I'm not even gonna try and do the
will Arnett intro movies should begin with
scary titles.
I can't do that gravelly voice really well
but there was a joke about every ridiculous
Batman character every movie every TV show
anything you could possibly make fun of this
movie did that in every single line of dialogue.
It was crazy.
They were probably a ton of Easter eggs that
I missed but there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Batman comment on this video here
we go there about 50 of these not including
all the different characters from the Batman
Canon there was some really ridiculous ones
too the number one the plane hijacked if the
beginning of the film is from MacGuffin airlines
just the idea that there's this plot device
driving things forward that doesn't really
mean anything.
It just something to get the plot to move
forward to the airplane is owned by Ferris
Eric Carol Baratz star sapphire and girlfriend
of Green Lantern Hal Jordan which showed up
during the Justice league sequences number
three Commissioner Gordon's partner is named
O'Hara a reference to chief O'Hara played
by Stanford Rapp I was gonna go ahead and
start numbering.
These are just a list is because there's so
many both egghead and condiment King completely
ridiculous Batman villains.
But totally true to the series, so condiment
King showed up during the animated series
egghead was played by Vincent Price on the
classic TV show they did a whole bunch of
special Lego and cards for the DC TV shows,
which will just play here
killer croc slide I did something is a reference
is bit of a dig at killer croc in suicide
squad who almost did nothing to service the
plot Doug Benson was the person voicing Bain
he did dark Knight rises bank, but he also
does that voice in real life all the time
on his podcast.
Doug loves movies the jokers line want to
get nuts.
Obviously a reference to Michael Keaton's
Batman for the 89 film when joker asked Batman
who your number one bad guy is he starts talking
about Superman that's a dig a Batman view
Superman.
There's a sign for Batman forever for the
1995 film that shows up there's a building
downtown called Shrek's department store which
is from Batman returns the second Michael
Keaton film in the Batcave, there's a lot
of the Easter eggs from the Batcave in the
comics the giant T Rex is sitting there.
That's from the 1946 Batman comic dinosaur
Island the photo Batman's parents taken in
front of the Monarch theater is also true
to the comics.
When offered is getting down Batman for the
different phases he goes through they flash
to every single Batman movie that's ever happened
in Lego with the exception of the super friends
cartoon.
The cartoon logo the live-action bad dance
from the 60s TV series in the 1943 serial
the original Batman serial they made Superman's
Fortress of solitude look just like the one
in the Richard Donner films there's a name
dropped for Bludhaven when Barbara Gordon
appears for the first time home tonight wing.
There's an add on the back of a magazine called
Baris automotive that the hat tip to George
Barris the person who designed the Batmobile
from the 60s TV series the laundry truck that
reads operated by Quinzell is actually a reference
to Harley Quinn a but then later it reads
Phantom zone, just a reference to Superman's
Phantom zone.
There were a bunch of outfits including Batman
costume Robin costumes the go all across the
canon that the characters wore when we see
Dick Grayson he's dressed just like 1960s
Dick Grayson and that redshirt the scene where
Alfred let's dig into the Batcave on purpose
is very reminiscent of Vicki Vale being led
into the Batcave on purpose.
It was a Batman beyond costume for everybody
this fan of that series.
The showed up when they were doing the dressing
montage the glasses that did Grayson wears
when he's dressed as Robin make him look just
like the Carrie Kelly version of Robin even
though he's Dick Grayson when the power of
the Batmobile they say atomic batteries to
power turbines to speed that's what they would
say when they were powering up the Batmobile
from the 60s TV series, when they go to the
Fortress of solitude the doorbell rings the
Jon Williams theme that was so great the banner
on the Fortress of solitude reads 57th annual
Justice league party this year is the 57th
anniversary of the Justice league and it was
the same thing for the Joker to he says this
is our 70+ anniversary it's been 70+ years
since the Joker debuted in the comics there
were a bunch of dance party Easter eggs wonder
dog is the DJ and had a couple characters
from the challenge of the super friends show
Apache chief and black bolt in the background
when Batman turns on the Fortress of solitude
looking for crystals throwing them Marlon
Brando's message comes on from the Jon Williams
movies Batman drops a gleaming the cube reference
when Robbins trying to steal the Phantom zone
projector he dumps his utility belt out as
he's trying to enter the prison they have
a total recall x-ray machine where they have
a fight is right out of the Schwarzenegger
movie.
The sheer number of villains that pour out
of the Phantom zone is ridiculous, so we have
Volta more.
But you know that Alfred is being played by
Ralph Fiennes who played Baltimore in the
Harry Potter movies so you have two Baltimore,
it's in the movie you have Godzilla you have
King Kong you have British robots that got
the biggest laugh out of me.
I don't know why they were able to call them
doll X maybe was a copyright reason, but they
also had flying monkeys from the Wizard of
Oz pre-much every genre villain that you could
possibly imagine.
There was even jaws which was a nice call
back to the shark repellent on the 60s TV
series all of it was useful is a sign for
Penguins club the iceberg allows the shows
up the Gotham Gazette shows up, that's also
where Vicki Vale worked during that Michael
Keaton Batman film they have a whole bunch
of soda or cola, which sounds weird but it
just a fictional DC comics soft drink that
first bat suit that Alfred shows up and before
he switches to his butler Batman costume is
from the 1960s TV series there is a huge suicide
squad dig during the movie when Batman's in
the prison and last at the idea of using criminals
to fight other criminals in the Joker drops
another Jack Nicholson reference where does
he get all those wonderful toys the gremlins
on the wing is actually a reference to twilight
zone William Shatner loses lawyers to see
them in the movie.
This was actually really obscure.
Let me know if you guys picked up on the gym
caught a reference is this really funny movie
about someone who fights crime and is a bad
ass with his gym skills so he does a lot of
high cakes a lot of flips it just the most
ridiculous movie ever the Batman family that
Batman is so afraid of putting together is
actually big thing in the comics there's a
lot more Robbins a lot more other people that
we are back costumes that are part of the
family, now but this was just one of the earliest
versions of the bat family Robin almost puts
on a night when costume when he's talking
about what would Batman do Nightwing was the
version of Robin that he became in the comics.
When they wanted to make an hardcore he was
growing up.
They wanted to put him in teen Titans.
So they give them a more hardcore costume
more hard-core attitude.
So anything I need to be like Batman that's
what that cost was all about the really awesome
one you had to be listen really closely, but
to face in the movie is voiced by Billy Dee
Williams who played to face in the Michael
Keaton Batman films but never actually got
to be to face he was only Harvey Dent he never
got acid in the face.
So he never got to be that evil persona and
probably one of the funniest, but most on
the nose Easter egg references was the entrance
password to the Batcave, Iron Man sucks, but
is a dig at the fact that Iron Man is another
billionaire in the comic book universe that
uses money to fight crime.
Let me know in the comments what other Easter
eggs you guys find, but it was a great movie.
I think as long as you understand it's gonna
be ridiculous going into it and I think is
a little more rewarding for long time Batman
fans is noticing an Easter egg in every single
line of dialogue he was crazy.
I feel like I would have to go back and see
it again just to catch a couple more that
I missed the first time but that aside, I'm
not planning on doing a big review video.
I feel like this movie doesn't need it, you
pretty much know what you're getting just
based on the premise it's gonna be ridiculous,
but as long as you understand that ill be
a lot of fun.
So congratulations to the newest flash ring
giveaway winner Cory Thacker please private
message me on the back end of my channel so
I can get your contact details what can happen
tomorrow is walking dead his backs will post
my new episode video will be new game of thrones
so be sure to look out for that what you wait
for that to post you can click here to catch
up with all the crazy marble stuff that drop
last night for infinity war and you can click
here for my latest flash video.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys next video!